donc je me présente je m'appelle les
rennais 5 dollars actuellement je suis
en tunisie j'ai un projet culinaire
c'est l'épicerie sheed qui est
spécialisé dans le culinaire les
produits de terroir les fromages et la
pâtisserie donc là c'est vrai que c'est
un changement à 180 degrés par rapport à
l'intérieur précédente où j'étais
heureux suite et niort et je travaillais
pour le sit & go donc gt5 manager en
soldes ce manager du groupe new york
avec des déplacements en afrique du sud
à doba et à l'antre j'ai signé mon
contrat avec city bank tunisie de mon
bureau à new york
j'ai continué à travailler là bas
pendant longtemps puis je me suis dit
que voilà un rêve d'enfant ce faire van
propre projet un projet est dans quelque
chose que j'adore une passion et c'est
toujours un business à l'événement c'est
un business et c'est un rêve et c'est
quelque chose c'est un défi mais un défi
qui commence à réussir vraiment et je
suis empreint de d'avoir le résultat je
suis en train de voir la réalité et la
reconnaissance dont les clients et ce
assez
plus grand acquis donc appris vous vous
demandez comment on peut faire toutes
ses études avec la lorsqu'on vous dire
j'ai eu la maîtrise de finance en
tunisie je suis parti vivre sur
bridgepoint cas où j'ai fait mon à
billets j'ai fait de concentration une
alliance et une entente marc hétier
après j'ai fait ma thèse de pitch qui
est comme après chirac aux états unis
enfin j'ai pas bousculé pour citigroup
ces documents contacts et avec avec un
poste de par l'étude grands dossiers
donc ils m'ont appelé je me suis dit si
groupe c'est quand même internationale
c'est quelque chose qui se trouve en
tunisie et probablement séjour que je
suis trop utiliser un port sd toute ma
vie ailleurs donc j'ai signé avec cet
humour là le premier challenge ça que ça
a commencé de new york en mai john
tunisienne qui se trouve ainsi du groupe
hybride parmi plus que north employés
comment elle va faire elle a des gosses
elle est un domaine où on voit le
chiffre en fin de trimestre et donc
c'est ou c'était un challenge
jusqu'à ce qu'un jour mon boss que je
n'oublierai jamais il venu me voir pour
me dire les là j'attends que tu sois
maintenant à belfast était rien pour ma
part de passer derrière les résultats
sont meilleurs
mugenzi est clair ils ne viennent fils
de
tison ok d'accord parmi douze de ses
branches toutes ses fonctions au guidon
de ma zhaoxu
bye bye nom paul castets et j'ai
travaillé d'arrache-pied sans avoir une
vision sur les chiffres sont bien du
tout on n'avait pas idée des résultats
des résultats des votes le fameux jour
on s'est réuni les représentants de tour
de tous les états des états unis
ils ont commencé à donner les résultats
de citigroup sont commencer par les
états fleurs l'état n'est pas ça et
j'étais assise et j'avais zéro espoir
que ça va être bon
sincèrement je sais je savais que j'ai
besoin de progresser mais pas au point
d'être la meilleure dont les trois états
qu'est-ce qui viennent aux trois états
et la surprise oui la prostituée sein de
mouna et l'acheteur et là j'ai pleuré
parce que la jeune fille de vingt six
ans qui a cru ensemble elles bien cru en
quelque chose pour cent dans le grand
est et comment télévision hervé l'ol si
on veut réussir au balo rip s'il n'y a
pas d'obstacle et a pas quelque chose
et en fait le buzz le côté négatif c'est
ça qui tue quand on a des visions
négatives contente ce qui est impossible
- je vais jamais réussir ce domaine
quand même je suis une tunisienne savez
là bas on sait que la tunisie
sincèrement à chaque fois que je leur
disais que je venais de la tunisie leur
unique était en tunisie
mais voilà et dont il fallait se décider
et tu déjà et ce dans ce cas tu es un
bric à ramallah il voit la panacée la
tunisie ces petits points à la rose et
la cuisine et et cet univers a réussi là
où elle voulait réussir
de la même façon de la même façon dont
j'ai décidé de rompre et en tunisie
j'ai demandé j'ai demandé est ce qu'il y
avait un moyen de reprendre mes
fonctions en tunisie je voulais rentrer
en tunisie pour des raisons familiales
de par le fait que j'ai pas j'avais
perdu de mon père mais tout ça tout ça
comme je voulais vraiment rentrer en
tunisie et je voulais aussi que mes deux
garçons profitable de l'éducation de
notre éducation ample qui complice
ajoute à la façon dont j'ai grandi mois
et leur papa et c'était votre charme je
pense que le ct d'autres postes d'autres
personnes qui voulait postuler pour ce
poste et c'est qui cette jeune fille qui
veut venir et prendre la direction de si
tu manques midi alors que nous on a des
prix aux militaires des gens qui ont une
expérience je sais pas combien d'années
donc je suis resté dehors et c'est tout
l'entretien de 15 minutes avec le big
boss à l'autre parce que je vous précise
et donc j'ai mis à 100% ce que nous
devons savoir toute mon expérience dans
un entretien avec quelqu'un que j'ai
jamais vu beaucoup oui ils désirent
cette unité à l'anglaisé les élèves qui
va prendre ses connaissances venus après
mon expérience avec le fameux à l'écran
certains perçoivent au collège je les
connais de père en fils et voilà donc le
palais fin donc après 15 ans de vie
financière
vous pouvez voir ça me travaille et à
l'esprit je voulais faire mon truc à moi
après ça moi ça pouvait être dans le
domaine financier
je pouvais enseigné dans une université
je pouvais faire des aveux de consulting
faire tout ça sauf que c'était pour vous
les bons ceux comment je cherchais je
cherchais à nîmes assainissement
personnel les études ça a été fait les
diplômes sont dans la poche le côté
finances et ça a été fait est resté
quelque chose qui n'était pas complet
encore c'était bondé personnellement à
moi c'est palm hills manderrier l'art en
tant que personne j'ai choisi un domaine
où figure
de plus ea domaine qui est le domaine
culinaire de l'épicerie fine dans
l'épicerie fine commencé c'est des
produits qui doivent être créés 0,2
l'errance pour les fautes
est ce que j'ai adoré dans tout ça c'est
travailler avec les femmes tunisiennes
et les vagues rural en crise donc mon
principe est découvert les très simple
toute femme tunisienne toute femme brune
ouvrira les portes sont grandes ouvertes
pour ces femmes-là donc toutes les
artisanes je travaille avec des fans de
kate
j'ai travaillé avec des fans qui sont à
la limite de la frontière algérienne je
travaille avec des femmes de quéroan je
travaille avec des femmes de l'art
j'habite un petit village à côté de ça
nous donnera la chapelle je travaille
avec des graines de djerba je travaille
avec des frappes de douceur et s'était
produit elles font d'elle même et c'est
grâce à ce travail là qu'elles font
vivre leurs familles et 15 élèves leur
remboursant donc on travaille toutes les
fermes en tunisie les produits nature et
le produit et le et des bombes ou jeu
j'essaye de ramener un peu de débouchés
des crises
il concerne un tout petit peu de
l'industriel en vie dans un pays où les
richesses au sénat où les capacités sont
énormes pour la femme tunisienne elle
excelle dans tous les domaines y compris
de noël culinaire pense que j'ai
rencontré des gens qui est des femmes
excellé dans le domaine
je suis en train de découvrir une autre
catégorie de femmes ces femmes des
femmes du milieu rural mais avec
l'expérience avec un savoir faire avec
nous volonté extraordinaire et c'est
après ce changement à 180 degrés je ne
sais pas si vous avez des questions
auxquelles je pourrai répondre
bah oui
[Applaudissements]